right hello everyone welcome to this
virtual talk i'll be talking about some
connections between sum of squares
in particular lower bounds for the sum
squares hierarchy based on high
dimensional expanders
and this is based on joint work with
irritanur you are filming central
darshan
and before we get to
high dimensional expanders let us just
recall expander graphs we all know and
love these objects these are graphs
which are well connected there are
combinatorial and spectral ways of
measuring
this kind of notion of expansion or how
well connected these graphs and they
have plethora of applications
to many areas in particular
re-randomization metric embeddings
pseudorandomness coding theory and then
there is an excellent
survey by huri lineal and victor sun
which
is a beautiful exposition of many of
these
constructions and their applications
dimensional expanders are just expanding
hyper graphs instead of graphs
and there are many ways of capturing
what it means to be
an expanding hyper graph not all of
these definitions are equivalent and
in particular we won't need to know too
much about the specifics of
these definitions for for this
discussion
during the talk but just to say that
there are many different ways of
defining an expanding hypergraph
and although these are kind of this is a
relatively recent area
it's already had a huge number of
applications and this is just
a non-exhaustive list
of papers uh just to illustrate that
there has been quite a few
results and quite a bit of activity some
of it quite surprising in the recent few
years and
uh in particular today i'll be talking
about some applications to
constructing uh instances which are hard
for
certain optimization algorithms or
certain families of algorithms
and the problem we'll be considering is
three xor or the maximization version of
three xor so you are given m
[Music]
constraints which are of the form of
linear equations over f two
in in boolean variables
and in let's say the total number of
variables is n total number of equations
is
m and your goal is to find an assignment
to the variables satisfying as many
equations as possible
alternatively we can think of an
instance as being described by
a collection of three tuples script t
which will form the left hand sides of
these equations and
a function beta which for each equation
gives you right hand side which is
either zero or one or is a
value in f2 and once such a collection
of tuples and beta is specified that's a
complete description of an instance
for 3x or max 3xr
and the family of optimization
algorithms will consider is
something called the sum of squares stp
hierarchy it's a
it's a family or a hierarchy of
semi-definite programming relaxations
which which captures many of the known
approximation algorithms it's a powerful
tool and we can think of it as a
computational model
the with the complexity kind of governed
by the levels of the hierarchy in
particular for
constraint satisfaction the level t can
be solved in time into the order t where
n is the number of variables
and we want to sort of understand
how well this computational model or how
much power do we need in this
computational model to obtain a certain
quality of approximation
in particular for 3xor
here is the relaxation given by
p levels of the hierarchy we don't need
to understand the precise form of this
relaxation for the talk
all i want you to you know see is that
it's it's a vector program or a
quadratic program in vectors with
one vector for every subset of variables
of size up to
t and that's roughly where the
parameterization
in terms of the levels of the hierarchy
comes from the larger
number of levels you are looking at
there will be vectors for larger and
larger subsets of variables
yeah we won't need to use the precise
form of this too much there's also an
alternative view of
viewing sum of squares in terms of
objects called pseudoexpectation
operators but
and then their equivalent the pseudo
expectation form is more convenient for
certain applications although
as i said we won't need the precise
description right now
what is interesting is that as i said
it's a powerful hierarchy we know a lot
of upper bounds or
many approximation guarantees we also
know quite a few lower bounds
but these lower bounds are essentially
derived
through some random instances or they
are non-constructive in nature um
uh lower bounds on on approximation by
the way uh
then i'll kind of illustrate uh clarify
that in a bit
uh
this kind of either are random instances
themselves or you can
start with let's say a random instance
of 3x or do some reduction on top of it
to derive an instance or some other
problem which we want to show a lower
bond for
and when i say
this kind of approximability i want to
distinguish between
cases where you show that the
hierarchy cannot find the true optimum
which
can be shown for explicit instances but
in those cases we don't always have like
a large gap between what the hierarchy
finds
and what the true optimum is these are
things like cythin tautologies improve
complexity which are basically some
systems of xor but
these are unsatisfiable equations which
are kind of almost satisfiable but the
hierarchy thinks they're completely
satisfiable so there is a slight gap but
not really
a large enough gap that it gives you
sort of
some constant factor in approximability
result or any kind of inner
proximability result
okay in terms of gaps for approximation
the previous known results for 3x or by
grigori when independently
it's discovered by shayna beck out of
the following form
you can show that there is a an infinite
family of three xr instances and in fact
these are just random instances
where you choose the tuples the three
tuples at random
fixed number of tuples each tuple chosen
at random the right hand side beta are
also chosen at random to be 0 or 1
and then can show that for such
a construction uh with high probability
it's true that no assignment satisfies
more than uh 51 of the constraints or
half plus epsilon fraction
uh but uh and this is the
kind of that's possible because you can
always satisfy half of them uh
just by a random assignment and
on the other hand the sos hierarchy kind
of fails maximally it thinks that
all constraints are satisfiable or it
cannot refute the instance which means
that it cannot even prove that the
instance is
not completely satisfiable so it thinks
fraction one of the constraints are
satisfiable
the instances i discussed in the talk
are
constructable in deterministic
polynomial time they are explicit
um but they are weaker in some ways
in particular the soundness or
what a true like what is true for any
actual integer assignment is that uh
not that cannot even satisfy 51 percent
but you cannot satisfy
something like 90 percent of the
constraints so think of mu
as point once there exists this constant
such that no assignment satisfies more
than one minus mu fraction
and on the other hand the sos hierarchy
still thinks that
the instances are completely satisfiable
it still cannot refute them but this is
we can only prove this for
about square root login levels of the
sos hierarchy as opposed to
n levels or omega of n levels of the sos
hierarchy which was true in the previous
results obtained by random constructions
some of yeah a couple of remarks some of
these things can be
handled so in particular
this issue of 1 minus mu you can get
around partially by reductions so
using starting with the explicit three
xor instances and doing some polynomial
time reduction on top of it
you can get instances where no more than
half plus epsilon fraction of the
instruments are satisfiable
by any actual integral assignment but
then sos thinks at least
one minus delta fraction of the
constraints are satisfiable
can't quite take delta to be zero but
the gap qualitatively is still almost
one versus half plus epsilon
and you can also use reductions to
get gaps for a lot of other optimization
problems
again the number of levels still stay
about square root log n you don't get
increased number of levels on the sos
hierarchy but you might lose a bit
depending on the reduction
so the best of our knowledge this is the
first explicit construction of the
integrality gaps which show hardness
approximation
in the sos hierarchy as i said
just showing that sos doesn't actually
the true optimum can be done
with explicit instances but if you want
to show an approximability gap
this is the first instance as far as i
know
and moreover the instances are not just
explicit they also have an interesting
structure in that sense they offer
an interesting contrast or maybe even an
apparent contradiction to previous
results where um
a recent result with
veda levy 11 fernando grana hajironimo
we showed that
three xor instances on high dimensional
expanders
are easy in the sense that a constant
number of levels of sos
can obtain an arbitrarily good or one
plus epsilon
approximation um in fact this is true
for all csps
but then here i am telling you that i
can give you
three xor instances on high dimensional
expanders which are
hard for even square root log n levels
of sos
so what's going on
and both these results are correct the
catch is that
they use a different definition of on or
rather what it means that an instance
is a csp on a high dimensional expander
and they use this high dimensional
expander slightly differently which is a
subtle
thing i'll illustrate in the next couple
of slides
but i just want to mention that kind of
the instances here are not just explicit
they also have some interesting
structural properties
okay now to illustrate
the structure of these instances like
sort of a while i kind of mentioned the
distinction
between these and the previous
algorithmic results let me also
sneak in a little bit of the simplicial
complex notation which we'll use later
so a simplicial complex
is just a fancy term for a downward
closed hypergraph so
think of hyper graph as having
hyper edges corresponding to subsets of
the vertices these subsets can be of
size 1
2 3 but we will always consider
hypergraphs to be downward closed which
means that if you have a size 3 subset
then it's
all its size 2 subsets are also present
as hyper edges
and in general we'll refer to
size 1 subsets as vertices size two
subsets as edges size three subsystems
triangles and so on
not necessarily in any geometric sense
so far although
the intuition comes from some geometric
connections but uh right now just as
three tuples and two tuples etcetera
and when we have a triangle we also have
all three of its edges present as hyper
edges in our micrograph
we will use this
notation x bracket j to denote the
collection of
all hyper edges of size j plus 1
and again the the discrepancy between j
and j plus 1 is just coming from the
geometric
intuition you think of a triangle as a
two-dimensional object
an edge or a line as a one-dimensional
object and so on and
so x bracket j kind of denotes
the j dimensional faces of the
simplicial complex or the subsets in
your hypergraph
hyperedges in your micrograph of idj
plus one
variables and constraints will
correspond to kind of different
sort of faces of different dimension in
our simplicial complex or different
levels
and and i'll illustrate this as we as we
go along with different constructions
uh let's first look at
a simple way of connecting three xor
instances with simplicial complexes so
recall the three xor instance is just a
collection of three tuples um
and an associated right hand side value
beta for every three double
we can think of these three
variables as vertices of a triangle so
we can think of
a simplicial complex where
all the variables are
vertices or
the dimension zero faces of the
simplicial complex
all the triangles correspond
correspond to constraints and are the
dimension two phases of the simplicial
complex
and we have this beta which maps
the set of dimension two faces to values
in zero one which corresponds to the
right hand side okay this is just
a translation or just stating things in
a different language i'm not doing
anything deep here
but for this kind of construction
it is known that known by recent results
that
if your simplicial complex is kind of a
high dimensional expander is a
sufficiently strong high dimensional
expander
then such instances are actually easy
for sos
and i'll refer to this as the vertex
variable construction
and in particular a constant number of
level levels of sos
can obtain a one plus epsilon
approximation the
to the true value where the the kind of
number of levels depends on epsilon
let's think of another way of
constructing simply uh
three xor instances from simplicial
complexes so
a triangle has three vertices but it
also has three edges
so the next construction i'll talk about
i'll refer to the edge variable
construction so
now let's say given a simplicial complex
the x2 which is a set of three
dimension two faces we are still going
to think of them as constraints
but our variables are now going to be
members of the set
x1 which is the set of one-dimensional
faces or
edges okay in sort of one-dimensional
phases of the simplicial complex
so a triangle still has three edges
which means that we still
have that every constraint has three
variables
and we still will think of
a function beta mapping x2
through 0 1 or the field f2 so we will
have
one right hand side for every equation
equation is just a member of x2
a variable is a member of x1 now
and in this work
we show that sort of this kind of a
three xor instance
constructed from a specific
family of simplicial complexes in
particular
the ramanujan complexes of lubotsky
samuels and vishney yield three xor
instances which are actually hard for
the sos hierarchy in particular square
root login levels of the sos hierarchy
fail to even refute uh
unsatisfiable instruct instances
constructed in this
this way so notice that
up to the description of the ramulojan
complex which i'm not actually going to
give in this talk um
but it's an explicit and kind of
explicit family
i've almost completely described the
three xor instance except that i have
not told you what these betas are which
are the right hand sides the left hand
sides are all governed by the structure
of the complex
we will come to this sort of beta a
little bit later but
i just want to illustrate the
distinction between this construction
and the edge variable construction where
the variables are vertices of the
triangle
and now in this construction the
variables are edges of the triangle
let me say a few words about how the
proof
works and
if you've seen sort of one of these
lower bounds
for for xor in the sos
hierarchy uh all of these have the
structure that
the first step is basically forgetting
about sos so
in particular instead you consider a
proof system which i'll call
xor resolution which is just you
look at two equations and use them to
derive a new equation by adding them
so you add the left hand sides which are
l one and l two and the right hand sides
which are
beta one and beta two and the goal is to
start with
all the equations which we are given as
part of our
three xor or xor system in general which
we will think of as axioms and we will
try to derive
new consequences of these axioms until
we derive 0 equals 1 which is a
contradiction
so we will have proved that our original
system of axioms is unsatisfiable or we
would have constructed a refutation
for the given xor system
and while we are doing this we will
measure the
width of our refutations so any
derivation of 0
equals 1 can be viewed as a dag where we
can
just kind of traverse the tag to kind of
reach the contradiction and
the on any node we will have an equation
with the left hand side and right hand
side and
the will think of the width of the node
as
the number of variables in the equation
written at the node
and the width of the entire dag or the
width of the entire proof has the
maximum number of variables appearing in
any node in the dag and
a very nice result of the even chain
back
shows that if
a low width sort of xor resolution
cannot refute
a given set of axioms or a given
collection of equations
then neither can sos so in particular if
xor resolution needs width test leads at
least w to derive a contradiction
or to refute then sos needs with
at least w over two so up to a factor of
two
sort of it's just sufficient to shift to
thinking about
this xor resolution proof system
and then
there's an argument of bensasson and
wigerson which
shows that random instances need very
large weights so in particular if you
think of
random instances where the set of three
tuples or the number of equations
is of size some constant times n
constant capital c
is chosen appropriately then
for a parameter r which will be roughly
the width
and then can be taken to be omega of n
you can show the following so first that
any refutation will contain an
intermediate node
which is derived from roughly r axioms
and
this kind of switch quickly r i am using
to denote various
quantities which will be between r over
2 and r so
instead of having to write this kind of
constant factors i'll just call all of
them as
r so there will be an intermediate node
which will be
about which will be derived from about r
axioms
in the dag and
they also show that in a random system
of
axioms or in a random 3x or formula if
you look at any set of
about r axioms then there will be
roughly are variables which will appear
in exactly one of these axioms so if you
think of set s
of axioms then there will be roughly r
variables which will appear in exactly
one
axiom in s in general
for set s of size up to r they will be
roughly size of s variables which will
appear in exactly one
equation or exactly one axiom and there
is something called the boundary
expansion and proof complexity
and so the width of such a node
is about r
or the number of variables which appear
in exactly one axiom because when you
add all these axioms
these variables will never cancel out
there is nothing else in s which can
cancel them out
okay so such a node in the dag will have
width r so any refutation will require
width about
r which means that sos will require
uh at about
r or r over 2 levels to refute such a
system
and r can be taken to omega to be about
omega n which is what gives the result
of
gregory event chain
and here we will also prove that the
instance is constructed from this
lubatsky samus and vishni complexes
need large width now the width will be
about square root log n
and so we will kind of have we will be
able to
prove something similar in particular
for r about
log n we can say that if you have a
refutation dag then there will be a node
which
sort of is derived from about our axioms
and the
the the role of boundary expansion and
proof complexity will now be played by
what's called the topological boundaries
so we'll show that
it's sort of an easy consequence of
what's called gromo's filling inequality
that
if you look at roughly r triangles then
there will be
about square root r variables or edges
which will appear in an odd number of
triangles okay
so
and you can think of an edge being on
the
kind of topological boundary it appears
in an odd number of triangles
so roughly though this picture is
slightly misleading you can think of
this picture of
kind of a planar grid where
r triangles can have a boundary of have
a boundary of size at least
square root r
and if this is the case this will show
that the width of such a node is square
root
r because notice that it's you didn't
really need the variables to appear
exactly once it's okay if they appear an
odd number of times when you still add
equations corresponding to all these
triangles
because the variables appear in odd
number of times they will not cancel out
they will still remain in the new
equation which is derived by adding
everything
so there will be about square root r
variables which will remain in the
equation obtained by adding
the kind of small equations
corresponding to each of these triangles
and this would be very nice except it's
actually false as stated
but it's sort of true and i'll say sort
of what modification
needs to be done okay so this picture as
i said is slightly misleading but
not not horribly so so
the issue is that recall that our
simplicial complex i also kind of
mentioned tetrahedra or faces of
dimension three or sets of size four
and if you look at all four triangles
which are present in a single
tetrahedron
then all edges
all six of the edges appear an even
number of times
so these are four triangles which have
no edges on the topological boundary or
no edges appearing in odd number of
times
and in particular if you consider a
collection of triangles which are just
union of disjoint tetrahedra then
nothing
appears in odd number of times no
variables or no edges appear odd number
of times
so in truth we have to work with a space
which is the kind of space of triangles
when you think of it as a vector space
um quotiented by
uh the the span of uh
kind of indicator vectors of tetrahedra
and you have to you know translate the
notions of
width and the the vensassen victressen
argument
to work over this kind of quotient space
but it's sort of morally the same
argument and
but once you are kind of working in this
space you can apply remote filling
inequality and then kind of carry out
the argument i mentioned on the previous
slide
another issue is that you also need to
prove
soundness that the instance you
constructed
is not satisfiable in fact is far from
satisfiable and in random instances this
can be just done by
choosing this right hand sides given by
beta at random
for every equation you choose the right
hand side at random and
if you fix a single assignment to all
variables for random right hand sides
there is
exponentially small probability that
more than 51 percent of the constraints
are satisfied by a given fixed
assignment
and the probability is so small its
exponential in the number of equations
that you can actually take a union bound
over all assignments and just doesn't
happen
we are trying for an explicit beta
something which is constructable in
polynomial time and in particular is not
random and we don't quite have the
luxity of taking the channel
so here we'll use some sort of
topological expansion properties
of the lsv complex to find a good
beta which which gives us this sort of
soundness property
and again tetrahedra kind of show up so
in particular we choose a beta which is
still a function from the space of
triangles to
f2 so just labeling of all equations
with 0 1 as the right hand side
which has two properties first no
assignment to
the edges which are the variables of our
equation satisfies all the constraints
so the
the beta is such that the system of
equations is not satisfiable
and just seems like this is the property
we want i'm just stating it up front but
i'm not saying it's far from satisfiable
i'm just saying it's not satisfiable
okay and i'll tell you how to find it or
i'll say a little bit
but then secondly we also want an
additional property that
these betas are not sort of quite
independent across triangles and
in particular if we look at all four
triangles which participate in a single
tetrahedron
recall that all edges in a single
tetrahedron
appear an even number of times if you go
over all triangles which means if you
look at the left hand sides for all
these equations
they will just add up to zero so the
right hand sides better add up to zero
if
the sos is supposed to think that these
equations are satisfiable this is a
local check
just on four triangles which can be used
to check whether the system is
satisfiable or not
so it at least should look locally
satisfiable
so we will choose betas in a way that
for every tetrahedron
the four right hand sides for the four
triangles in that tetrahedra
tetrahedron add up to zero
and uh this can be done
and in particular uh
this is related to a space called the co
homology which is the
kind of the quotient of all the betas
which satisfy the second property
and don't satisfy the first one so
the quotient of all beta satisfy the
satisfying second property
uh with respect to all betas which
actually do arise from
edge assignments um uh the ratio of
these two is called the cohomology and
uh samus and vishnu actually proved that
the the
the homology and in particular this is
called the second co homology of the
simplicial complex is
non-trivial and so you can find a beta
which
satisfies both the things that i wrote
above
but such a beta guarantees that the
instance we get
is unsatisfiable you cannot completely
satisfy all constraints
we still need a little more to say that
it's actually far from satisfiable
and this comes from a property called or
this is a consequence of property called
core systolic expansion
proved by abraham kaufman where you can
show that
once you pick a beta satisfying the
above properties
uh it's not just
something which is not satisfiable by
edge assignments
but it's actually far from anything
which can be satisfied by edge
assignment so it's sort of like a code
this quotient space
the homology and is at least
mu far for some fixed constant mu which
means that
no more than one minus mu fraction of
our equations are satisfiable
once you have this kind of a beta there
is an efficient description for these
and you can actually explicitly pick one
of them
you get an instance and roughly
using the kind of analysis of analysis i
mentioned you can
prove the soundness and completeness
i'll not say much more about the proof
right now but you will come to ask more
questions in the slack channel
for the paper or just send one of the
authors an email and we'll be happy to
answer all you can catch us during one
of the break times
in in tcs and
just in terms of open problems
yeah i mean this is barely just kind of
scratching the surface of connections
between high dimensional expanders and
sos in some sense
there is this kind of weird contrast
between the vertex variable and the edge
variable
construction so there's something which
would be better to
kind of understand more deeply we
currently stop at square root login
levels and
if you think about it i mean the square
root login kind of comes for the same
reason why
some of the earlier gaps stopped at
login levels when working with random
sparse graphs just like
a random sparse graph
looks like a tree up to
radius log n
and in also explicit constructions like
the lps
expander is the quotient of uh
an infinite tree which looks uh like the
tree for
log n size balls
the the lsv complex or the ramunujan
complex looks like
an object called an affine building up
to radius
log n and that's where this square root
log n comes from you apply
actually almost filling in equality in
this affine building rather than
in the complex itself but
for for random graphs we do know
gaps which can go beyond the girth
there or the login
and so it's possible that here also we
can go beyond the square root login
although we don't quite know how to do
that yet
and of course it will be great to have
further applications of high dimensional
expanders
and understand their connections to
other areas and theoretical computer
science better
thank you for your attention you are
welcome to join us
in the conference discussions or in the
session for the paper or
on slack and we'll be happy to answer
any questions